I have a quick question to launch it off
so as much as the beauty of being able
to quell the ego is so important for
civilization where does that come into
play for children how do we know how do
we know at what age and like is it
appropriate it's and it's not
appropriate for everyone so what are you
what are your thoughts about that
yeah I don't know when when it's
advisable for people to start using
psychedelics and I haven't really
explored that but it's important to
understand that the structures that
psychedelics melt are formed you know a
little later in life young children I
talk about young children in the book
and in fact there's a whole passage
about this brilliant child psychologist
at Berkeley who really believes that the
consciousness of children under 5 or so
is very similar to the psychedelic
consciousness and she basically thinks
little kids are tripping all the time
and they if you've had one you know that
they do and but they don't have a
default mode network we haven't talked
about that but that's the network in the
brain that appears to go quiet or be
quieted during the psychedelic
experience that doesn't develop till
they go to school and begin to develop a
sense of themselves as consistent beings
over time that you know you're not born
feeling that way and you know
personality doesn't really kind of gel
until your early 20s so it's a curious
time to to dissolve your personality
before that
and you know for some people it's fine
and for other people it's I think very
challenging and one quick follow-up to
that and it's something that I think
many people are curious about where do
we strike a balance between nationalism
and globalism seems to be one of the
most pressing things that's going on in
the world is how do we beat foster a
collective consciousness across the
globe but also how do we ensure that we
can thrive as the United States at the
same time where do you how do you strike
a balance with that as well well you
know I think one of the interesting
things about psychedelics is that they
potentially address two of the biggest
challenges we face as a civilization one
is the environmental crisis our
disconnection from nature and the other
is tribalism our disconnection from
people who are unlike us one of the
amazing things that happens on a
successful psychedelic experience is a
reconnection
with nature you you no longer objectify
the other one of the things the ego does
is patrol these borders between self and
other self and nature and self and
subconscious and when you put those down
when you quiet those voices is when you
can connect to the other in a very
profound way and and I described
experiences I had with nature where I
saw nature in a completely different way
I was part of it part and parcel of it
not an observer not a spectator and did
it with other people I mean the most
common you know experience people report
is this feeling of this flood of love
for other people whether in their lives
or people very unlike them and you know
is there anything we need more right now
the challenge is though how do you go
from creating those experiences in
individuals to creating it across the
society and we there is no model for
administering a drug to an entire
society Mike microdose the whole foods
buffet well or I mean we do have we do
have fluoride but I think psychedelics
are very different than fluoride